when everything is going good
you can do stupid stuff and it feels
like it's smart because it works every
anyway there's enough good things going
on that it overcomes you're stupid you
know
but when stupid is stress tested is when
things slow down and all of a sudden
stupid starts looking stupid it shows up
you know and so when your little plan
gets stress tested stupid will pop up
and that's true of your little financial
plan too
you know I'm gonna I'm gonna borrow and
I'm gonna do nothing down real estate
and I'm gonna get deeply in debt and as
soon as the economy turns you're gonna
be bankrupt you know how I know that cuz
it happened to me cuz I was stupid so
there you go
my little plan got stressed tested by an
economy shift an economic shift a
banking climate shift and the banker
looked down and I'm kind of scared of
real estate now I really liked real
estate about 20 minutes ago and now I'm
scared and then they called our dadgum
notes and we spent the next two and a
half years of our life losing our butts
and you know whose fault that was mine
because my plan that I thought was
brilliant was working fine when
everything was going fine but when it
was stress tested it turned out to be
stupid and see that's the beauty of
being debt-free you stress tests that
you look smart borrowing money up to
your eyeballs and everything's going
good I can afford it does not mean you
can pay the payments I can afford it
means you have the money to pay the item
in full right then so if you're driving
a car with car payments that means you
got it bought a car you can't afford if
you're buying Christmas gifts on a
credit card you're buying Christmas
gifts
you can't afford otherwise you would
have just paid for it that's how you
know you can afford it it's a real easy
formula let's see when things get bad
when you lose the job when someone gets
sick when the economic situation changes
and your stupid get stressed dress
tested aha there you go and that's what
happens when you hire the wrong real
stage which what happens when you were
have the wrong tax person when you have
the wrong investment broker and you
start reading the wrong books and doing
some of the stuff some of these people
say to do oh my goodness yeah as soon as
you put stress on it you I mean when the
tide goes out Warren Buffett said you
can tell it was skinny-dipping that's
what's happening a stress test
stress test you're stupid and you can
tell what's up and you'll find out I was
getting away with that because there was
enough good things going on with my
income and with the economy that I
didn't I couldn't tell how bad this was
but now that he got a little stress put
on it you're like ouch this hurts